السلطات الايرانيه تواصل تجاهل اصوات
الاحتجاجات والتمديدات وتستمر في التضيق
على المتظاهرين اخر القرارات القمعيه هو
التشديد في المخالفات المرتبطه بقانون
الحجاب الالزمي والتي كانت الاساس في
اطلاق الشرارات هذه الاحتجاجات خطاب
السلطات القضائيه كان شديد اللهجه حيث امر
المدعي العام الايراني قوه حفظ النظام
بتوقيف كل ما يخالف قوانين الحجاب
الالزاميه والتطبيقي عواقب صارمه في حقه
ومن شان هذا القرار تاجيل الشارع الايراني
بشكل اكبر سيما وان رفض القواعد الصارمه
لللباس كانت من اهم النقاط التي تمركزت
حولها الاحتجاجات والمظاهرات وفي خطوه
اضافيه كذلك لتضييق الخناقه مجددا على
النساء خلال الفتره المقبله قامت السلطات
الايرانيه باغلاق عدد من المقاهي والمطاعم
على خلفيه عدم التزام روادها بوضع الحجاب
كما استانف تحذيره مالكيه السيارات من عدم
التزام السيدات علمتها بقواعد اللباس
ويبدو ان من مطرقه القضاء تحولت الى اداه
في يد السلطه الايرانيه لتصفيه حساباتها
وذلك في ظل احكام الاعدام المتتاليه فضلا
عن محاكمه شخصيات معروفه كما هو الحال
بالنسبه لفائزه رقصا جاني ابنه الرئيس
الايراني الاسبق اكبر هاشمي رفسا جوني
والتي حكم عليها بالسجن لخمس سنوات بسبب
التحريض على اعمال الشغب محاميه ابنه
الرئيس الايرانيه الاسبق اكدت ان موكلتها
ستطعن في الحكم وستلجا لمحكمه التمييز
وتعد ابنه رخصه الجاني واحده من بين
العديد من الشخصيات الكبرى التي تؤيد
الاحتجاجات وتنتقد القمع الممارسه على
المتظاهرين فمن هي ابرز الشخصيات الاخرى
التي تحمل امال الايرانيين في الداخل
والخارج
[موسيقى]